-Performing "O Holy Night"
from her album "My Gift,"
once again, Carrie Underwood.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ O Holy night ♪
♪ The stars are
brightly shining ♪
♪ It is the night ♪
♪ Of our dear savior's birth ♪
♪♪
♪ Long lay the world ♪
♪ In sin and error pining ♪
♪ Till He appear ♪
♪ And the soul felt its worth ♪
♪♪
♪ A thrill of hope ♪
♪ The weary world rejoices ♪
♪ For yonder breaks ♪
♪ A new and glorious morn ♪
♪ Fall on your knees ♪
♪ O hear the Angel voices ♪
♪ O night divine ♪
♪ O night ♪
♪ When Christ was born ♪
♪ Divine ♪
♪ O night ♪
♪ O night divine ♪
♪♪
♪ Truly He taught us ♪
♪ To love one another ♪
♪ His law is love ♪
♪ And His gospel is peace ♪
♪♪
♪ Chains shall He break ♪
♪ For His child is our brother ♪
♪ And in His name ♪
♪ All oppression shall cease ♪
♪ Sweet hymns of joy ♪
♪ In grateful chorus raise we ♪
♪ Let all within us ♪
♪ Praise His holy name ♪
♪ Christ is the Lord ♪
♪ The name forever praise we ♪
♪ Noel, Noel ♪
♪ O night ♪
♪ O night divine ♪
♪ Noel ♪
♪ Noe-e-el ♪
♪ O night ♪
♪ O Holy ♪
♪ Night ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]